(upbeat classical music)
- You guys wanna see something sick?
- Oh my God!
- Nice, man.
- Thanks, dude.
- You alright?
(coughs)
- Oh, really?
- Alex.
- Alex!
(slide whistle)
- Ah! Fuck!
- Oh, hey!
- We're still on for later, right?
- Yeah, totally!
- Agh!
- I know.
- Yeah, I don't know, he's
like, really standoffish, and,
- I don't know, it's just
not currently working out.
- New shirt?
- Looks good, I like it!
- I don't really know why,
maybe I did something,
but I'm pretty sure I didn't, you know?
- Uh huh, yeah...
(mellow romantic music)
- Hey, Garrett.
- Hey, Maggie.
- Hey, what's up?
- Hey!
- Which chapter are we on, again?
- Uh, it's 25.
- 25?
- Doozy.
(coughs)
- You okay? You want some...
(water splashes)
- Sorry.
- Fuckin' tissues.
- Come on.
Shit.
("Salon Meeting" by Milan Svoboda)